talk this morning is about nutrient
management practices on on small
livestock Farms I'm not going to get a
lot of detail about how to actually do a
nutrient management plan on a small farm
I guess that's going to probably vary
from from source to source to Source but
I want to talk about some practices
we've found or I've found that I think
are are good guidelines that small farms
ought to ought to be following and good
recommendations we can make I guess the
biggest question is uh what do you think
is a small farm I mean it's kind of Soup
To Nuts in a way here's uh you know 25
goats here's a couple hundred dairy cows
that are
grazing there's a few chickens on a farm
that happened to be pretty much a
managerie for
foul um 500 milking use this pretty cool
farm been there lots of times uh they
produce artisan cheese for a very
high-end Market if you want to spend $35
a pound for cheese you should come to
that that
farm um a 35 St
Farm some beef cows 65 or 70 head a
breeding Farm of horses so a small farm
um kind of across the board a little bit
so I'm I'm not going to throw out a
question for you here but I'd like you
to think just what makes a small farm
small um could be acreage um sometimes
Farms on small farms are very very
limited acreage they're small
um you know 20 goats on five Farms I
guess that would qualify as a small farm
animal numbers sometimes low but again
that can vary um 150 Cow Dairy Farm
would be considered small in much of the
country um and in some parts of the
country it would be considered quite
large uh small farms may have a special
kind of a market they're they're
producing for some kind of a niche
market um small farm uh um meat being
produced for a for a specialty trade of
some kind height well I'm just joking
there 5 fo2 I guess would be height well
this is the USDA answer uh for a small
farm a small farmer is defined as one
that grows and sells between $1,000 and
$250,000 per year in agricultural
products again that's a nice big range
uh to look at uh$
250,000 what's that 75 dairy cows you
know is that about right I think that's
probably in the realm of uh uh what it
might be maybe 100 dairy cows a
th000 $1,000 I guess below that we'd we
we'd be looking more at uh maybe kind of
a hobby farm and this is going to vary
by States a lot of states are going to
have um uh Farmland tax assessments that
are going to require a certain amount of
income to qualify for that Farmland tax
assessment in our state we only required
$500 of income to actually qualify for
Farmland tax Assessments in some other
states it might be quite a bit more than
that so again that's the USDA definition
um this comes off of usda's we side they
kind of divide between more of a let's
just call Residential or I don't I don't
want to use the term Hobby Farms but
retirement Farms lifestyle Farms um
there's a major there's an occupation
there other than just
farming um and then more what we'd call
an intermediate uh Family Farms probably
still less than that $250,000 gross um
they report farming as their major occup
uh occupation low sales Farms might have
less than $100,000 uh in sales High
sales farms between1 and
$250,000 in in sales so it's a pretty
pretty broad look we're we're looking at
um this kind of interesting uh from the
the 2007 census of
farms if you look at that um
$250,000 from less than $10,000 to up to
$250,000
60% um of of all those Farms of of all
Farms not just the $250,000 Farms 60% of
all Farms are less than $10,000 of
sales okay six and 10 Farms have less
than $10,000 in sales land in farms well
that's lower
18% um cattle inventory 9% horse
inventory 65% of our horse farms are on
those less than $10,000 of of income and
often times I wonder where horse income
comes from I'm not not sure so much in
my state where how they're actually
making money unless they're part of
other other kind of uh you know
Endeavors on the same
Farm okay we may not use the we may use
another governmental um um
recommendation and this would be the
EPA um uh approach you know we can um
we're all familiar with Kos small Kos
medium Kos um a small farm would be um a
small C would be less than 300 head of
of beef ve or dairy less than 200 dairy
cattle less than 750 swine uh that are
greater than 55 lbs 3,000 swine less
than 55 lb 16,500 turkeys 37,000
chickens 3,000 sheep 150 horses so by
the the EPA standard that would be what
we're um where we're
uh what what would what they would
considered to be a small
farm I like to maybe talk about what
I'll call small farm distinctives for
just a little bit generally smaller
Farms are going to have less animals
fewer animals and because of that
they're going to have less waste to
handle okay um they might have some
other problems related to having that
waste but they're going to have less
waste to handle they're not going to
have the volume that or the amount that
other Farms
have quite often they don't have a
suitable storage structure I know that
most small farms that I go on in my
state they probably they may have a
designated area for manure
it all goes here it all goes in the
woods um but quite often they don't have
any kind of a designated structure
unless they've gotten generally in some
sort of government program that helps
them get a
structure um they probably have less
land available for
grazing um they probably have less land
available for
spreading in in fact when it comes to
most horse farms uh they don't want to
spread it anyway they want to get rid of
it if they can they just assume haul it
offside um and generally operators have
less experience in Waste
Management closer to neighbors
probably they're they're often located
in some small uh um small regions or a
local that where they may be totally
surrounded by an urban area so they
might have more neighbor concerns than
someone else is going to
have they probably have a limited budget
budget for manure handling and
storage however in some areas you know
some Farmers tend to be more affl and
would have would have income or dollars
for that
that they might have the option of
disposing the offside now this is
something that larger Farms probably
don't have such an option for they might
but a lot of small farms would if they
can they'd like to haul it off site
unfortunately sometimes offsite means in
a
dumpster uh that gets hauled to the
landfill sometimes it might mean just
stored off in the woods somewhere
um composting might be an option in fact
a lot of small farm you'll ask you'll
ask they compost and they say oh yeah I
compost but I think generally there's
not a lot of understanding what compost
means it might to some people it might
mean that I keep it in a pile for a year
and after it rots I try to get somebody
to come and pick it up so that wouldn't
really be
composting uh less aware of manure
management bmps probably so um I put a
um a question mark there because I think
often times uh newer or beginning
farmers are more open open to uh Waste
Management ideas than maybe some more
established farmers are they're new they
want to learn and and they might be more
um you know more interested in and more
willing to make some
changes well let's go back to this that
uh that uh I'm sure we've all seen this
diagram many times um or or similar
diagrams that we've got uh nutrients
coming onto a farm we've got nutrients
that are exiting the farm we we've got
um nutrients that are causing balances
or imbalances in the in the soil now I
think
it's I think actually getting Farmers to
address if they're a small farm with not
a lot of acreage getting them to uh
accept the idea of actually spreading
and managing and nutrient management
plans on farms it's probably going to be
kind of difficult um but I think we can
focus on things like imbalances ways
they can uh they can get around that
that
concern and of course manur storages are
one of the ways we can do that
now the these are some guidelines we use
on small farms in our state in fact we
use these guidelines for all farms in
New Jersey but most of our Farms are on
the smaller side anyway
um so and this is the basic of our
nutrient management requirements within
the state but I think they're a good set
of guidelines uh our first point is we
we always encourage our producers to
store their manure in a dry level
impermeable
location or as impermeable as possible
free from Storm water runoff location
should be at least 100 ft from Waters or
Wetlands that comes right off of our
state regulations so I I think that's a
good thing we can we can look at on
small farms if they don't have good
storages now we can encourage them to um
at least consider how they're storing
their
manure secondly each Farm should have a
plan for managing manure spreading and
Disposal now
disposal if disposal is an option then
uh then then I think Farmers small farms
should be uh should be encouraged to do
that we have a number of uh centralized
uh small centralized composting areas in
our state which pick up mostly horse
horse manur but they they get manure
from other sources as well but it's all
small farm manur they compost it and
then they Market it as
mulch managing storm water so so your
the water stays out of uh uh out of your
manur pad out of your manur storage um
might require the use of some buffers or
some vegetative filters and I'll show
you some slides in a couple moments of
that um controlling animal access to
streams and waterways again that's right
uh right out of our state regulations um
and again does sometimes animals have to
have access to waterways if they if they
or or or streams if that's their only
source of water uh consumption so um but
that include fencing maybe some uh
stream Crossings control farmer oan and
finally being aware of those neighbor
concerns
um we asked a survey of horse Farmers
how many of you how many of them dispose
of manura off Farm over 40% of them diso
uh uh dispose of manura off the
farm I mentioned you a centralized
composter this is a guy that does that
he comes he's in the northern part of
the state he comes and he does a variety
of things he'll do a he'll do a if you
got manur stacked up for 10 years he'll
come and he'll he'll haul it off and
he'll compost it and he has regular
contracts with certain Farmers where
he'll leave a dumpster at the farm a
roll off and he'll pick it up on a
regular
basis Min
storage now again sometimes smaller
Farms don't have a lot of dollars they
may not be able to put up a a a storage
that has a roof on it or proper proper
storage for solid manure so um what this
Farmer's done is he's got he's put down
a mostly a gravel pad which is a three
sides on
it it's a relatively impermeable base or
we hope that it
is it's um 100t from Waters or
wetlands and it's um got a vegetative
filter on the back side of it so I think
that's a good recommendation for a small
farm they don't have to put up an
elaborate uh concrete pad um they can
put up a relatively simple structure
like this that allows them to store
their manure
want them to keep water out of uh uh
their animals out of water there's a
there's a dry lot just to the right
there which was a you know a muddy mess
so they shouldn't have been storing
their manure um the way they were um
right by that stream which is in a
sensitive Watershed anyway um this is a
a farm that had several hundred horses
um he thought he had a good system there
you know had Woods on the one side Woods
on the other a graveyard on the other
side
and uh and that's what his storage
looked like it was a mess now he's
changed that subsequently made some
changes but had water way on the side
there so I guess if you're talking The
Good the Bad and the Ugly this is
probably the
ugly um this is a a farm we assisted a
few years ago they had previously stored
all their all their
manure um on on one on one field right
along a ditch which ended ended up going
into a string so we came in we helped
them put up this this small composting
uh uh pad that you see which uh
certainly took away some of their
concerns this is actually on our campus
uh for our horse farm you know we've I
like want to point out that nice Vegeta
buffer on the on the downward side of
the of the storage so again the storage
doesn't needs to be adequate in size to
meet your needs we've got a 35 well foot
well vegetated buffer uh to uptake
nutrients that come out of that storage
so I'm not for small farms I'm not a big
proponent of of roofs on stor small
storages maybe in certain environments
rainfall Etc you you you have to
consider that but I think there's other
things that can be uh considered that
are more cost- effective Okay order to
store and spread again you have to make
um proper investigations of your area um
streams Lakes aquifers slopes for
spreading
neighbors now here's something that that
that I will generally tell people that
on a small farm if you're spreading man
on a small farm I don't think it really
does you any good to take a lot of
manure samples for your spreading
particular if you're spreading every day
um you might you might spread over the
you might take samples over the course
of a year and come up with a baseline
but in general I think using book values
is probably about as good as you're
going to get uh for an accurate uh
estimate um on a smaller
Farm okay here's a a spreader
that's a spreader for you milk Creek
spreader being pulled by a uh um by a an
ATV
vehicle and there are plenty of these
mil Creek spreaders available at least
in our area farmers who who use
these I think we should always be
encouraging Farmers kind of regardless
of their size to develop a farm map
think they ought have an idea what's
what and what's where on their Farm they
need to know where the water's at um
they need to know where the slopes are
and based on that they need to they need
to be able to make some uh adjustments
and some um plans about where they're
going to spread and where they're not
going to spread now if they don't have a
a map such as this which they can
probably get for the local Soil
Conservation District or nrcs or you
know Google Maps for that matter um
there's number of sources they can get
decent maps from they can draw their own
um that's but but they need to some idea
where their manur is um going and how
they're managing their
Farm sacrifice areas now I mentioned I'm
a pretty big proponent of storages I'm
also a big supporter of sacrifice areas
if you can now what's sacrifice are is
that where I'm going to kill my sheep no
that's not um some people might call it
an exercise lot or a rest lot or a dry
lot um it's an area where our animals
can kind of congregate we can feed them
in that spot we can water them in that
spot they could have some shelter in
that area they it could be a
semi-confined area which would probably
let them have some some access to
pastures and and grazing areas that are
outside of that
lot um sometimes we would include what
we call a heavy use pad around the
waterers especially um which is we've
excavated some of the dirt around it we
put in some kind of a geotextile pad and
then maybe a couple of different layers
of stone to uh eliminate the mud that
would be around the watering area um
to use a sacrifice area on your farm and
um about half of our producers uh uh
said that they did of some kind this is
horse producers
again and here's a not a real good uh
thing to to kind of uh not a good kind
of a sacrifice area to have just one
great big lot where they graze and they
feed and they water the same place
here's kind of the idea and I got this
out of a of a publication from I think
it was University of Kentucky kind of a
you know you got your dry dry lot area
and then um where your animals are and
then you have fences out to your
rotational pastures I think we we did a
survey recently looking at nutrient
management practices on horse farms
especially looking at feed management I
think the things we one of the things I
came out of it with is that sacrifice
areas and rotational grazing if you can
get Farmers horse producers to do those
things that's good I mean those are
those are good management practices that
uh hopefully they'll follow again of
course good uh well-managed pastures are
always going to take up more nutrients
than uh poorly poorly managed passengers
and of course you get that whole
recycling thing going um with your
horses or with animals in general poorly
vegetated passengers are not going to
take up as many
nutrients um erosion I
mentioned
so when when that's a possibility stream
Crossings are are are possible nrcs can
help design these and maybe help fund
them too okay again I went through those
those kind of six areas storage disposal
and spreading storm water management um
access to streams and waterways erosion
neighbors and finally just kind of
putting it all together small farms can
have some unique challenges because of
um their size both acreage and animal
numbers there's not enough land for
spreading there's probably a lack of
understanding of nutrient management
requirements lack of familiarity with
bmps it may be located uh in in or near
populated areas those those neighbors
those urbanized neighbors that might
surround us they probably don't many of
them don't have a good understanding of
what we do and why we do it um they may
be able to dispose of waste offsite
which is which is positive provid it's
not going to
landfill um and beginning on New farmers
May willingly make changes again I think
that that's a
possibility um small farmers small
farmers don't always fit existing models
that might work for a larger farm for
manure management so patience is
required and if you want to see a nice
fact sheet on on nutrient management go
to the E extension website and you'll
find a fact sheet there by a guy named
Randall Randall James I think it is he's
done a nice little program for how you
manage a manur on a small Farm Ando and
opposed to looking at it as just so many
pounds
produced per given time period he does
it by by time okay my cows produce so
many so many so much manure for for two
months so two months storage goes here
two month storage goes here so it's a
take a look at it it's
helpful any questions